there's a local event happening to help
our community understand
the risks of marijuana and alcohol rocky
spoke with care coalition and shadow
hills church to learn more
so we're talking about the care
coalition some an organization that does
such good work in our community so
ladera let's just talk about what you
guys do and
introduce us to the care coalition we
are a substance abuse prevention
nonprofit organization here in
southern nevada basically our services
are to provide help to um
pretty much any demographic that needs
to help with
dealing with substance abuse um what we
do with the prevention side of things we
don't do treatment
um a lot of people get that mistaken a
lot um we are the ones that kind of
provide the services
of trying to prevent the substance abuse
from happening in the first place so
that's just a little bit about us thank
you so much for what you guys do
um peter i want to have you chime in
here on what
what this looks like for us in the
community in particular i get to
interact with a lot of youth
who are already turning to substance
abuse whether it be marijuana whether it
be alcohol
a lot of the reasons because it's so
easily accessible in our city
but also because they're just broken and
so we're partnering
with the care coalition to create the
awareness of not only
education regarding the substance abuse
and the ease of access but also the
importance of turning away from
like how do you educate yourselves and
why is that important to know
to make the right decisions for your
life that's beautiful and we have this
partnership going on with care coalition
and shadow hills church
what is the special event you guys are
putting on for the community and how can
we get involved and help
we are working with shadow hills and
this event is basically to bring
parents in the youth together to kind of
bring awareness to the risks and the
harms associated with drug use
um so basically we're going to be having
you know
food while supplies last we're going to
have vendors there we're going to have
activities so that we can
kind of get it get the information into
these people's hands
but in a fun way good good make it make
it something that they can enjoy
and also be educated at right exactly
so who's invited who are you talking to
specifically
anyone's invited we do have a
eventbrite link that we've been sending
everybody to
um and we are capping the event at 800
people so the first 800 people to sign
up
you know that you're more than welcome
to join um
and yeah we're it's pretty much open to
anybody in the community that would like
to
show up any encouraging words for
someone out there that
might be struggling with drugs and
alcohol like if you want to do better
for yourself then
you should go out and go do that and you
know that's something that we kind of
pride ourselves on here at care
coalition is
being able to see uh people want to make
those changes and being able to
see the growth and you know along the
way along the process so
i also think people need to understand
that there's not a
too far gone moment in life like i truly
believe that
yeah you can get low you can have a
despair moment
but there's always an option and an
opportunity to move forward
in hope you just need the right guidance
and the right people by your side
this free event is open to the public on
wednesday june 9th
at shadow hills church from 6 p.m to 9
00 pm
you must rsvp only 800 free tickets are
available
for more information on care coalition
call 702
463-1415 or visit care coalition
nv.org las vegas now we'll be right back